ah oh it's nice so it works okay hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to oxygen not included
let's just pretend let's just pretend
like nothing went wrong now Bob back and
we do that yeah I bet we can we live in
our own little fantasy bubble where
everything is fine is everything good
hey are you guys doing welcome to uh the
stream that's working perfectly for the
first time and nothing's gonna go wrong
in my computer isn't random we're gonna
start restarting on me so uh yeah how
are you guys doing good here alright so
we're gonna get back into it we got to
go back into tiny blood hole and if you
guys don't know what I'm talking about
then you weren't here for the last
stream I mean there was no last stream
what are you guys talking about
everything went great the first time and
everything is wonderful and hunky-dory
in this fantasy world that I live in but
we're gonna go into tiny butthole not
tiny butthole tiny butt hole it's like
big big boyfriend not big boyfriend big
boyfriend my big boyfriend
not big boyfriend anyway how you guys
doing oh you're watching from the toilet
hey for all you know I could be too for
all you know I'm sitting on the toilet
right now I just happened to soundproof
my bathroom it was a little too echoey
for me too much of a singing chamber for
my taste but yeah so welcome back
everybody as you can see we're currently
in the depths of space and everything is
not as horrible as it may seem I mean
it's pretty bad judging by the the
status of everything else has been going
on here but hey how you going hi fluffy
Dino hi it's so fast
Sulu the wanderer hello Patrick starfish
wabby hello the walking Pop Tart hello
Noah the awesome kid hello everybody
hello hello hello hello hello Harrison
Jaynes hello the crazy swimmer how are
you guys doing welcome to the stream one
and all welcome welcome welcome I hope
you have a wonderful time here in this
one
under full stream okay so we're back
into it maybe everything's terrible but
I'm gonna keep pressing on yeah so what
happened is the stream was going fine
for a while and then I my computer I
it's my own fault because my computer
said that it was like hey we're gonna
restart do you want to postpone till
later or not later or set a time and he
was like restart now set a time or later
and I thought later was gonna mean like
hours later there was no notice on it it
was just suddenly like were restarting
now and I started spamming escaped in
control of delete and then I tried to
continue streaming like that and that
went horribly awry and then suddenly
everything was awful in the stream and
also I think doing the the ultra-low
latency mode was not as good I mean this
ain't mixer we're streaming on its its
youtube so okay get things going here so
we're back into it everything's
wonderful hello everybody
oh people are still streaming in thank
you I know oh you like the thumbnail
thank you I did not work very hard on it
at all but welcome everybody thanks for
joining me here and we're gonna get back
into the game so we got a little bit of
a boo we got a little bit of a setup
going on here everybody's got a certain
thing that's why would you stand on top
of the rock that you're dying you know
what I'm not gonna get mad at this
because that's just gonna lead to some
bad stuff so for now we're gonna act
like everything is fine and these
wonderful wonderful people he's
wonderful truly unimaginably wonderful
duplicants are just the best also I
remembered I got to uh I gotta build
some carbon dioxide beaters over there
oh no a fart er no way farter they just
fart out natural no they fart out
natural gas which is a super weird thing
they don't fart out polluted oxygen
anymore because that would be weird if
you shot oxygen out of your be whole but
supposedly supposedly that's natural gas
and eventually there's a new thing where
you can burn natural gas to be able to
do
what you need to do but I don't like any
of you feel far so I'm just going to say
no to you and then I'm gonna come back
when I get a better one later later much
later
okay so we got plumbing we go we need
interior decor because we need to make
this place a little bit nicer for
everybody in here so I'm gonna build
because I just need to build one and
then one there and then eventually I'll
build eventually if I could get the
temperature controlled I would build the
brittle brittle brittle brittle blossoms
I would build the brittle blossoms and
the may they would be able to do what
they needed to do natural gas yeah I
know I'll be able to get that I'll be
able to get that ever will be able to
get that
hi hello III yeah I know Chad's hard to
read but hopefully it'll settle down in
a little bit after everyone gets super
excited Stream is just the most exciting
you guys have ever seen but try to
contain yourselves all right so where we
stand right now at what ah so this is
one of the new things there are now
these buildings in uh strewn about the
entire place there's these buildings
that you can get into and they have
these what are called neural facilitator
and these things give your duplicants
whoever goes in there the brain gets
sucked all out and squeezed into your
duplicate because as I've said many
times before these little shits are just
dumb as rocks but they can be massaged
into a slightly less dumb way by
squeezing a brain into their brain so
this brain gets closed in and they get
another positive trait you know like mol
hands or divers lungs they get a random
new one but the trick is this place is
full of slime long there I suppose I
could dig in through there but that'd be
good but even though this slime is pure
about that eventually you can get some
purity stuff by getting chlorine I don't
know where there's any clue here no
that's hydrogen I are we go chlorine you
can pump chlorine into what's called
like a an or refiner or something like
that and that will cause the ore to
become cleansed of all its germs it's
another that's what I was saying about
the cleanroom that you can build but it
takes so many layers to be able to do
that that like would it even be
at the end of it would it even be worth
it at the end of it would I what I have
my sanity intact to be able to do that
the answer is yes probably and yes I do
like space do job simulator I don't know
I haven't had my VR setup in a while I
keep saying that I'm gonna set up my VR
again but I don't know I just like I
just get lazy look if I'm gonna be
perfectly honest with myself like I
could do it but I just get I get super
lazy about it because what I keep doing
this thing where I want like my VR setup
to be ideal the ideal environment for
your VR and be able to do all the stuff
but I just haven't had the space for it
anymore because we don't have that
office space where we where I used to do
it and now
like I don't know I miss doing it in the
old house that I had and just that big
bedroom I had that would have been a
great thing oh thank you this is this is
a good stream have you seen streams have
you seen them oh and the pole dancing
video Tyler's knee is almost better so
then we're gonna get that under way not
to not throw Tyler under the bus there
it is his knee has been detrimental to
our pole dancing ability all right so
with all that being said and done though
we do have a conundrum because once we
get our food operation up and running we
will need we're gonna need we're going
to see the thing about this game right
now we need to think about problems way
before they actually happen see water
consumption is at a minimum because we
have these things but we are gonna need
power we're gonna or we're gonna need to
make oxygen production through just the
algae deoxidizers soon but then once you
start that you start burning actual gal
G which once you run out of algae you
have to go into the other areas to get
algae like there's the first place to go
is the chlorine area because they have
algae just sitting out and they have
sand which is a filtration medium I
can't go this way because it's in fact
oh yeah oh I do want to play Binding of
Isaac again I think that's another good
streaming game oh and I will play dream
daddy one more time I was debating
playing dream daddy today but I kinda
wanted to play this just because I've
been super into this game lately and you
know me I'm a sucker for games that I
like you know I can't I can't not do it
because oh man but I'll get to dream
daddy again we'll finish that up and
Crash Bandicoot I still mean to finish
that like there's so many things that I
mean to finish but I get so sidetracked
like with the singing stuff like I do
get sidetracked on those things that I
get sidetracked by those things and I I
want to do am i I always want to do it
but I'll get there eventually just give
me some time let me be alright so now
that I got that research all done know
I'm empty that toilet okay you better
finish what you started over there
because I'm gonna be very pissed if we
end up with another shitty problem all
right so we got that um we need to start
thinking about the decorum in this place
because it's a garbage heap as it is
it's a nice bathroom art can we get a
bathroom sculpting block right here just
right by the [ __ ] over here this one
a this is it's a perfect place for art I
think when you're taking a dump over on
the toilet and rubbing germs all over
your face I think the best place for art
is right there organ sin enjoy oh good
we have nobody with any creativity well
isn't that common you piece of garbage
you couldn't hold it for two seconds
why didn't you go any of the other times
that it wasn't full you piece of [ __ ]
Abe you're getting germs everywhere Abe
you piece of garbage how could you bring
that way I totally do you're covered in
doodoo oh god I'm gonna make you out
asses then that's that's what we're
gonna do and how about you fricking mop
up your mess
how about you do that that'd be great do
that god
there's so there's such shitty little
kids that's what they are they're just
shitty kids now they're not even oh oh
the polluted piss and [ __ ] got in my
good water both of them maybe not this
one but god damn it you did someone [ __ ]
themselves on the goddamn ladder oh god
I have to clean up your goddamn mess you
son of a [ __ ] now got a mop this up oh
just mop it up please just build the
other outhouse and get on with it you oh
I hate you I hate all of you Abe it
wasn't just a BL [ __ ] themselves
did you guys see was it Turner that was
Turner got a band Turner the only one
that's got his [ __ ] together and by [ __ ]
together I mean in his own ass it's true
ball though hey you guys are making a
mess out of everything over here okay
yeah pieces of garbage oh god damn it oh
now you're just gonna go to sleep you're
gonna go to sleep without building that
other outhouse we're gonna [ __ ] all over
the place
you got freaking everything going wrong
up can't be mad at them they're my
children right that's how this works
they're my children so I gotta I gotta
be there for my children when they need
me the most
ah not a happy camper
okay well at least they clean that up
but we still got the problem because now
this is infected everything here cuz
this is that's just there now and now if
they ever pull from that water you why
you didn't wash your hands what is wrong
with you
Abe you're infected now it's okay
they're children I just got to let my
children be children right they want to
rub [ __ ] all over themselves and eat it
oh oh now you're washing your hand Abe
now you are now you are you know what I
forgets my fault I forgot to set these
only direction left you know i'ma set
this one direction both but this one
buried left only left oh yah yah yah
imma god damn Abe able of you able of
you baby I love you I love you Abe love
you love you love you but you know what
I just mmm
I can't no just no okay all right so now
that we got that crisis out of the way
oh good nice sculpture you really did
good here Oh crude level you know I
couldn't tell that by the giant hole
that you carved in a rock you know you
didn't even really try anything I think
the decor actually went down because of
that but you know what I'm gonna leave
it has to be these guys are trying and
you know what I can't fault them for
actually I totally can't fault them for
trying because they didn't even try hard
but you know what it's alright it's
gonna be okay cuz I'm a patient father
I'm a patient father I'm gonna sing
lullabies put him to sleep I guess I
shouldn't you know I shouldn't be too
mad because I didn't name this place
tiny butt hole so it makes sense that
there's poop everywhere I just just want
to throw that out there as a possibility
as to why this is all going wrong
but I've got like I was like I'll
settling down like you know I'm gonna
nights I'm gonna have a nice chill
stream it's gonna be awesome people are
gonna hang out I'm gonna talk to you
guys I can see you guys right there all
right cuz you chat right the father
replied don't ever say that again but
just just like I thought I was gonna
have a nice chill day and then
everything decided to go horribly wrong
I mean but you know that's how life is
you got to smile it out and I had such a
good morning I had such a good morning
this morning you know cuz I came up with
I was having a great morning because one
of the things I do if I if I ever want
to put myself in a good mood right away
like I imagine that there's two sports
commentators like really stereotypical
football commentators that are just
having a nice little conversation about
everything I do like they're in my head
and they're talking about me so as I
went to the bathroom I was like they'd
be like oh oh oh oh we lifted the toilet
seat oh what a champion oh we flushed it
what a smart most people would forget
about that right Jim yeah you said it
Jim it's just the gyms in my head that
are talking about it oh god is so funny
but yeah it just puts me in a good mood
and I'm just suddenly like hey well
that's nice well good I'm glad I did and
then and then I just have that going on
for a while oh you put his pants on oh
my gosh and if I actually forget some
ugly butt around in his pocket and you
just do that for a while then you just
you know you kind of put a smile on your
face because he's like I know it's
[ __ ] but hey maybe me putting my
pants on was a genius maneuver today
pretty good you know I am pretty good at
putting my pants on again can't deny
that can't deny skill wear skill can't
be denied and then you just do that for
a while so if you guys ever want you
guys ever want a little pet me up you
know a little little good old happy to
go lucky pick me up just imagine there's
two sports commentators just imagine
John Madden in your head debating up a
storm about how great the pie are we so
stressed
it's alright just imagine to sports
commentators in your ad talking about
how great you're doing and now imagine
for these little shits that I'm the
sports commentator and I'm not
complimenting a damn thing because they
got nothing to compliment here oh the
stress is at fifty eight by the way you
can't see it but it's way too high oh
yeah yeah
okay so I've actually been talking too
much I haven't been planning out what I
need to do so what I need to do is I
need to make a massage parlor but first
I need to make what we need is we need
to quorum right because this place is
just apparently terrible whatever can't
imagine why
there's only [ __ ] everywhere Oh what we
need to do is we need to make storage
that's what we need to do okay
so we're gonna make storage and we're
gonna combo the storage by also making a
nice little more for other thing okay so
I'm gonna make a multi-level storage and
then we're gonna put starch kadai later
little little little very little okay
that'll just be a nice pet project for
them to do when I'm I'm talking to you
guys which what I'd rather be doing and
then not have that you know what I mean
yeah that's what I'm gonna do oh yeah I
okay so I should play The Sims again now
man yeah if you if you think that I
think these guys are stupid what do you
think I'm gonna do when I'm encountered
with Sims and I have to deal with their
[ __ ]
every single day of my life no I don't
think I'm gonna do that I think I'm
gonna I think I'm gonna keep my sanity
intact and not go out of my mind at an
early age you know what I mean I think
I'm just gonna let let bygones be
bygones and just enjoy my life as it
stands okay how's the Durham situation
oh good the germs are kind of like
fading on it's not that many germs so I
guess we're gonna be okay on that
department anyway but let bygones be
bygones
okay all right so I think we've run out
of oxalate yeah it looks like all the
oxalate that we add is gone so we have
to start producing oxygen or else we're
gonna run out of it right now we have a
good amount of breathable gas but it's
one of those things where if you don't
think about these little [ __ ]
they're just gonna you know they're
gonna up and die and they're not even
gonna know why they're gonna be like oh
I can't breathe no do stupid bear [ __ ]
but pants you know that's what they're
gonna be doing well I'm gonna be here
yelling at them for not being smart
enough to take care of themselves but
alas such is the way that it is all
right the other thing though I want to
do is I want to create a unlike an
unending Wow no we need to all right
here comes the challenge we got to
conglomerate these water piles because
I'm ride on have a lot of access to
build out because this is all basically
in the way so I got to drain this down
to here and then I got a drain this one
down here and then I can clear it out so
that'll be the other pet project that we
got going on we're gonna build these
channels first just like this that's a
beaut right there that's a that's a real
beaut you're painting oh why don't you
just finger paint while you're at it
shitty brass is this really the most
important thing I like I said algae
deoxidizer the the oxygen thing and you
[ __ ] are so goddamn stressed
I wonder why cuz you're so busy [ __ ]
yourselves that and painting paintings
you can't you've got problems you think
that maybe if you put the storage
containers there you wouldn't have to
deal with all this [ __ ] on the ground
and that maybe you might have a funner
time in life oh yeah no no these are
these are wonderful
these are wonderful pieces of art this
like Mike first cover song level of
wonderful you know starting out from a
real crude baseline and then hopefully
going up from there alright let's see if
we can get one smarty up in here Oh
Oh Oh uncultured even better
Nikola you're a hero
look at you I don't know but I like Jean
jeans pretty cool they both have
irritable bowel you have an iron gut oh
that's nice but you've got such low
expectations ooh but you got better work
I'm gonna go Jean sorry Nicola like Jean
go I like Jean like Jean low
expectations anyway okay Jane you're the
only scientist you're the only smart one
Oh actually they got some good learning
so I'm gonna let you all learn but Jane
I'm sorry to throw you into this horror
show I feel like you're gonna be the
only competent one here but uh you know
bygones be bygones and whatnot they say
and who does it you know that thing that
I'm just talking about you know okay you
don't know but either way just buckle up
it's about to get bad all right so what
do we need to do are they got their busy
work so how you guys rip jean is gonna
be lonely here I you you don't know
about half of it you don't know the half
of it oh man oh jeez
I'm not gonna fit I know I know you guys
are all mad because oh I'm not
specializing right away but I've only
got four you know I can't exactly
specialize when I only got four I'm
gonna fix him if there was things to
select for research and art that's what
I could understand everything else not
gonna do that yet I'm gonna do that yet
right
also I gotta do this reel so not gonna
be able to build a crosshair doodly-doo
doodly-doo Lee that's not gonna be big
enough to hold it all but eventually you
know tiny butthole is gonna get a little
girthier if you know what I mean so I'm
gonna keep it but the important thing is
keeping it at for for a good long time
because to be perfectly honest having
more than four at any given time is just
especially in the early phase you're
gonna run out of oxygen you're gonna
just be running this race to like try to
get all of these different things up and
running and it's just it's not gonna be
good so I'm gonna build number one I'm
gonna build a massage table right there
so that people can actually get some
stress down which is not ideal right now
but
it'll be fine the stress is gonna be
fine I don't even care if they're all
destructive but tiny butthole will
survive not so not so tiny butthole it's
like dad did somebody's I think I think
there's something that I saw but III
don't think I come up with it but tiny
tiny butthole is tiny box Tim's best
friend or like you know what I'm
actually not gonna come down that road
because nevermind you know what forget I
said anything because frankly it doesn't
need to be said right I'm gonna make
this the algae one just good you forget
I said absolutely anything at all
because I'm an idiot and you know you
know I shouldn't I'm still talking about
it what about it oh you guys do it
you're good okay cool
all right Oh tiny but anyway let's move
on be a little bit more mature about
other lives why don't we do that okay so
this algae the oxidizer should be enough
to provide oxygen for the whole base so
long did we got enough power for it oh
look look this is if this wasn't a
perfect example of what's going wrong in
this gene has to power this massage
table so that Abe can get some
relaxation gene has to slave away to
keep these other guys happy that's
what's going on here and that's it oh
man if that isn't telegraph and
everything bad about this whole
experience here I don't know what would
I don't know what would oh oh also I did
this backwards I need to make this and
then need to make these these the those
and then these that these you know what
I mean because that way it keeps the
decor away from them during their sleep
and if they have bad decor when they
sleep they're not gonna be too happy are
they
not no they're not okay you go there you
go there you go there you go there and
then eventually eventually we're gonna
have some good stuff going on here ah
yeah I do remember alien isolation I do
I really do
yeah alien isolation was a good one I I
wish they had done more DLC I wish
they'd have done more story-based DLC is
the thing about that because their story
based DLC was really really good you
know I was hoping that it was gonna be
like more robust but you know that it
was such you didn't bill I priority 9 DS
why didn't you build them you know gene
is the only one that deserves a bed oh
look at these stupid pieces of [ __ ] look
at these stupid they're so stupid they
can't even understand the fact that I
needed to build the base for their bed
and big about their that dumb genes the
only one that did it that's how dumb
they are it's that's the perfect thing
Jane is the only still oh my god they're
so dumb it's at priority 9 that it's
priority 9 I can't but what are they
even doing it otherwise what do they do
it there is there is a priority 9 how do
you how do you how do how do how does it
even happen I have no idea oh my god I
know stop the infected water there's
nothing to be done about it okay as I
can see there isn't any more infected
water anymore I've got it all contained
over here in a [ __ ] hole okay they did
it okay Oh hatch kill that thing
whatever alright I need to get okay we
researched refrigeration so now I need
to come up with a more robust power
supply power is like the other thing
that causes so many like headaches for
me because it's uh what they did was
they made it so that power is just you
know it's a goddamn nightmare that's
what it is but they made it so that you
had to like the wiring will overload if
there's too much in this power like you
can this circuit can only handle a
thousand watts or one kilowatt and so in
order to have
all in order than you need like you just
need it you need to take them it you
need to strangle them it's what you need
to do you just need to strangle the
wires until they're good but what you
really need to do is you need to build a
giant battery department basically you
need to build uh I should get power
regulation before I do that but I'm
gonna let them finish that good genes a
smarty but you need to build a big
battery department with heavy wiring not
this light limp noodle wiring you need
to get that the hefty like wires you
know what I'm talking about the beefy
heavy oh not not light heavy wire and
then when you get that yeah you'll
you'll have it there you go that didn't
did I make that clear enough for you
guys you understand what I'm talking
about here okay hopefully all right
let's dig this out let's not do it there
and let's dig this one yeah let's just
dig this whole thing out I mean what's
the worst that could happen right what's
the worse that could happen it
everything will go wrong Yeah right
everything's already gone right why
would I be worried about anything else
going wrong Hey
okay so if they're gonna be we're gonna
in there for a while so yeah this is
slow mode this is this is slow mode yeah
believe it or not this is slow mode yeah
so uh don't forget the pineapple pizza I
have not I did forget the pineapple visa
but I will I will do pineapple pizza I
I'll try to get it tonight I'll try to
get it tonight but um my favorite pizza
Papa John's Papa's in the house doesn't
deliver to where I am right now so so I
I'm not gonna eat Domino's so maybe
maybe maybe because I don't like dominos
if I get their pineapple pizza I'll like
it or maybe maybe you'll paint it in the
wrong light I got to give it them I got
to give it the best and the pole dancing
video will be on the way because Tyler's
knee is almost better and he's gonna be
all 100% soon water what are you gonna
do about that huh what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do about that you
gonna you gonna grab life by the balls
and you're gonna build like a proper
water sucker thing you know what I mean
water sucker you know what I'm talking
about
yeah Oh west of loathing welcome West
clothing will also come I got so
sidetracked I got so unbelievably
sidetracked by getting that cover ready
because number one like I I wanted it to
be good like I wanted it to be good
enough because what I've always said
about my videos and what I do is I want
to put out the best that I can do at
that moment because that's all you can
do because if you strive for perfection
if you strive for perfection then you
will never achieve it because you you
can't I can't compare myself to the
level of quality that like other people
who are doing covers are doing it I
can't compare myself to how ed Sheeran
doesn't you know I can only compare it
to the best that I can do and so when I
went in this hole to try to do that
cover and I had only been trying to do
that cover for like when I started it
like two days before I actually did it
was the only time that I actually did it
but when I did it like I I was
approaching it and I had to fight my
mindset of like perfectionist because
I'm very good at making videos better go
to yes but I'm very good at I'm very
good at what I do right now in terms of
like let's plays and stuff like that but
I'm not good at doing covers or singing
or stuff like that and that's a skill
that I'm gonna refine over time but when
it came to that video like I I threw
myself into it 100% like I let nothing
get in the way of what I was doing and I
was consumed by it and I got to the
point where I was able to play the songs
capably and my fingers were hurting so
bad after the words but it was like pop
go sue ya gotta do it but it was it was
just so unbelievably stressful to me but
the best part was that when I when I had
an end product which was a video that I
had recorded and I got through the whole
song whether it was whether it was like
good or bad I got through it okay I
looked at it and I was like oh that's
not awful like that's not terrible it's
not great it's not good it's not refined
it wasn't perfect but it was good enough
that I looked at that and I went yeah
that's yeah that's the best that I can
do right now and that's a good
representation of my skill so then I
took that and I was like I'm gonna throw
this out on the internet and see what
people think and frankly I I really
didn't care if people liked it or not
like I I did that for me and I think
that's a very healthy way for people to
approach anything artistic or creative
that they do you when you put something
out there there's got to be critics and
obviously there were critics of my my
like cover like there's that and there's
unwarranted advice which is like just
totally unnecessary but it there when it
comes down to those things like it's
it's so important that when you present
something out there that you are proud
of it first and foremost because so long
as you always make stuff that you're
proud of you're always going to improve
and you're always going to keep getting
better and then your standards get
raised and then your standards get
raised again you put more work into
something you put your your your level
of being proud of your work increases
but you have to put something out there
and don't let anyone else knock you down
from it so that you can keep building on
what you want and that's that's like the
mindset that I took for when I was doing
that cover but it did consume my entire
life which is what I'd love to do I love
to let things just absolutely take
everything everything everything
everything everything like into what I
do and let nothing get in my way you
know what I mean like that's my favorite
thing to do so that's what I'll get
going and that's what well as I talking
about I have no idea these little shits
that's what I was talking about now when
it comes to creativity for these little
shits I'm gonna criticize them to the
end of the day I don't care if they are
proud of these [ __ ] paintings look
at this Garbo I don't even think they
could have done any better and I still
hate them for it I hate them for drying
look at this garbage here oh why does
Jean put up with any of this I have no
idea she's a saint that's what she is
I built way too many storage compactor
but you know what I don't care it's
gonna be storage heaven over here who's
gonna be there never gonna want for
nothing this is for the eventualities of
planning that's stored to the entire map
but anyway so what was that Doug about
oh yeah also uh how many people have got
a ticket for the tour
they're almost sold out for this October
leg but if you go down in the
description you can go - markiplier com
and if you go into any video you can
find a link there but we are going on
tour we are doing a show we got a big
old comedy show right now I don't need
this in fact there are this in fact you
see any infect a Cheniere huh I need
your your advice I've already on it if
they filled [ __ ] their pants we're gonna
be just fine in here so don't worry
about a thing but uh yeah we're going on
tour so if you got a ticket y'all cool
yeah we want to come to Canada we do we
we swear we do we're not ignoring Canada
but when it comes down to these things
it's all about the venue's it comes down
to the venue's and what's available like
when it comes to Canada like i-i-i
didn't even like pick like which I
didn't have a saying that because I
don't know that world that's all up to
like the the touring people like they
they're the ones that go out and they do
the math and they do like do the
analysis and whatnot and I will make a
very concerted effort and I'll say next
time we go out we will go to Canada
because I want to go to Canada but we we
just like we did what we had to and I'm
sorry if we were unable to go to your
state oh we are going to Kentucky we are
going to Kentucky if you haven't seen
that we are and Australia is also in in
the books and so is Asia the show I
don't know I just I really love the show
if you guys haven't seen the show if is
anyone here that went to one of our
shows can you guys like give a little
Testament of what the show is like
because the show was so much fun
not not just for us performing but also
for I'd like to think that the people
watching had a great time at the show
because it's it's not just like us doing
Let's Plays for those that don't know
what we're doing we have a full comedy
show we have like choreography we have
costumes we have games that we play we
have audience participation we have like
audience voting we have we have people
coming on stage we have like it's just
so much fun to be able to do and so much
fun to be able to bring it out there so
it was it was rough like in June but
again like what I was saying before it
was rough in June but it was the best
that we could do at that time and in
that time we built a pretty damn good
show like I'm really really proud of it
like
I when I said when I when I set out to
do it with my friends I was like I want
to do a show that we can all be proud of
and that people that aren't even a fan
of our of my channel or any of our
channels would love to see and would
love to see again and that's the other
great thing about it is it's different
every time because it one it's based of
improv but also there's different
versions of the show and you guys pick
it at the beginning of the show like I
like we put so much effort into this and
I can't wait to show you guys and also
I'm gonna be singing at the beginning of
the shows for those that get a VIP
ticket so all in all it just makes it
makes a great place oh yeah I was gonna
say we're going to Louisville Kentucky
we're going to Akron Ohio we've got two
shows now the 7:30 show of Akron was
sold out so we added another one so
anyone that wants to go to Ohio the Ohio
show in Akron which is near Cleveland
there's a 3:00 p.m. so now we're gonna
Rosemont Illinois we're going to
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Boston
Massachusetts Upper Darby Pennsylvania
Orlando Florida Atlanta Georgia and
Nashville Tennessee that's in October in
January we're gonna be going back again
I'll get that in just a second we're
gonna be going to st. Louis Missouri
Kansas City Missouri Denver Colorado
Salt Lake City Las Vegas Los Angeles
Phoenix San Diego San Francisco we're
doing two shows in Seattle once again
the evening show of Seattle was sold out
so we put another one there and then
we're going to Portland Oregon so we're
gonna be covering those and then in
February we're going to Europe we're
going to Europe we're going to Tilburg
in the Netherlands we're going to
Antwerp in Belgium we're going to Paris
France we're going to Amsterdam twice
we're going to London carat Cardiff
Manchester Glasgow Nottingham we're
going to Cologne Germany and Berlin in
Germany so that that I'm really excited
for because I've never really been to
Europe I've been to the UK but only for
three days and I didn't even get to see
any of it so I just can't wait to do it
so just check out the website it's
markiplier comm for anybody that wants
to see where those tickets are and if
you haven't gotten the ticket yet like I
actively encourage you not not just out
of my own self-interest because it's
it's not like doing it's not like doing
a tour is more beneficial to me than
doing Let's Plays in fact it's like at
this stream we have
seventeen to twenty thousand people here
like we got a ton of people here like
and that's more than we could ever fit
in a theater but just being able to go
out and like see you guys and perform
for you guys
is such a cool feeling like something
that we never thought we'd be able to do
it's something that we never really
imagined ourselves doing in and that's
kind of what lit the fire under my feet
about wanting to do singing and stuff
like that
is that it gave me such a rush to be out
on that stage like a lot of people who
have done theater can probably
understand that feeling it's it's just
it's something that can't be explained
something that can't be described when
because doing a live stream like this in
front of thousands of people is one
thing and it's amazing but being there
in front of you guys in hearing the
crowd and hearing you guys like cheer
and making you guys laugh onstage like
that's that is that is incredible like I
can't even explain what that is like you
know you know it's just it's such a good
good feeling also the Frick is going on
why haven't they harvested these things
you stupid pieces of carbo why haven't
you artists did it I have no idea I
don't have enough people to specialize
yet into harvest no yeah go to sleep
yeah go to sleep and just these guys are
so stupid anyway it's a lot of fun and
I'm I just if you've never gone to one
of our shows before please do if you've
never gone to a show before in general
like come to ours like I don't want to
I'm not gonna brag our show is really
damn good like I'm not I like I I I'm
not even bragging about it like I well
I'm kind of bragging but I'm obviously
bragging about it but like when it comes
down to the show it's fun
it's such a fun show like I I would love
to do this like if my youtube career
ever died like it's just it's just a
freaking fun show like it's so fun to do
because I love improv and and like I I
may be amateur at singing but God when
it comes to doing improv like I'm
getting good at it like I'm really proud
of the progress that I made like I'm not
the funniest guy ever but God at least I
can craft a scene and that's that's more
than I could have said before and and
like
just that's good oh they can't reach it
you guys are right I'm dumb ah cool
welp um the shows are not sold out then
the October ones are almost sold out I
don't know if you guys will be able to
get one for that we did add a second
show in Akron Ohio there is a second
show there with with tickets left but
most of the other places are actually
getting pretty close check them for
yourself but they're pretty close to
sold out right now but even so if you
can snag a ticket go for it go -
markiplier comm and check it out but
yeah it's just fun like god it's fun and
that's that's like I was just talking
with the guys about this you know it's
talking about nail making videos for the
sake of having fun and not like focusing
on it as a job because in the end in the
end like that's what it's all about
right that's what YouTube was all about
originally that's what it was all about
he was like hanging out with your
friends playing games being goofs like
just any excuse to make it laugh and not
apologizing for you know like just not
being funny you know you know what I
mean like it's just like I'd always and
funny but you know someone's gonna laugh
at it and that's that's pretty nice you
know kind of having that attitude about
it now I'm not talking about anything
else I'm just talking about from a pure
objective standpoint of having fun
making videos whether your videos are
gaming or whether they're sketch comedy
or whether what they're doing like you
got to have fun with it or else
I mean honestly what's the point like
why why why would you be doing it if it
wasn't fun cuz I'm like I'm obviously
I'm still young but I know I'm getting
I'm getting up to the point where I'm
like a real adult and and I I feel like
I I just don't have time to not do
something that I don't enjoy you know
what I mean do any of us like even like
I'm 28 and and like I I'm reaching this
point where I'm just like yeah I got to
be careful with how I spend my time so
why wouldn't I do things that I enjoy
but you know
even if you're young like why would you
waste time on doing something that you
didn't love you know I just I I wish I
wish I know that not everyone's in a
situation where they can do that but
it's it's just like it's why are you
Suffolk you stupid piece of Garbo oh my
god you better build Oh No yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah everything's fine
yeah Oh I mean when it comes to school I
know I said thing why why would you
bother doing things that you don't enjoy
when it comes to high school finish that
[ __ ] finish it unless you've got
something absolutely amazing that it's
working out so well for you there's a
certain the reason the reason I
emphasize high school you know college
it's whatever you want but high school
that's just to catch up to everybody
else you know the high school is to get
you to the base level of education that
society is that that's high schools
objective finish that so that you're at
least mentally on the same plane as
everybody else not saying not saying
that if you don't finish high school
you're not as smart as everybody else
that's not what I'm saying
do not misconstrue that in any way I'm
not saying that high school is perfect
and it gets everybody the same place but
just generally speaking know yourself to
the point where that's your bar to set
for yourself that's like the stuff they
stuff that they teach in high school
that's that the the content they're in
that you're supposed to learn learn that
whether that's in high school or
homeschooling or GED whatever that is
like learn that there's a certain
expectation to be like self sufficient
in terms of teaching yourself like I'm
not saying I'm not saying that if you
don't finish high school you're stupid
that's not what I'm saying I'm saying if
you don't learn what you're supposed to
learn then that's bad you know so
do that I can hear it like already going
to Twitter mark sensitive everyone's
stupider than he is yeah
can't believe you said that but that
sounds like something he'd say so I
guess we're gonna believe it all right
anyway so what was I saying besides
making an ass out of myself yeah
Oh pursue your trick dreams
yeah wouldn't a so am i anyway yeah
pursue your dreams what was I talking
about
I have no idea some some some some some
some was I saying
thumbs up I have no idea anyway the tour
oh yeah yeah I'm getting myself in
trouble here alright so yeah the tour we
just why do we have no woah-oh I'm not
paying attention this is what I get for
talking too much
alright anyway so they're gonna get that
out of the way and then we're gonna
build a liquid bottle er right there oh
[ __ ] all right there you all right there
we go there we go okay so the tour it's
fun get tickets while you can the
October session is almost sold out but
definitely check because I know there's
tickets left on a lot of those and then
January there's more tickets available
for them so check that out back to the
game back to these stupid idiots being
stupid idiots and then me know better
but I'm still gonna criticize them so
here we go alright Minnesota needs me
alright maybe what's my favorite song oh
man that's hard to say what are you guys
listening to nowadays like that's what I
really like is because I've been
listening on Spotify a lot and then just
I've been I've been every time I run
down from one artist it suggests me like
another one based on what I like and
it's almost scary because I'm like I do
like this but I don't like that you
suggested it you know I don't like that
you like I don't like that you know I
would like it but you know it's just one
Slayer oh hell [ __ ] thirty Seconds to
Mars yeah it's funny because when I was
in high school like I I actually didn't
pursue music very much oh and a lot of
people were asking like um death metal
yeah I I know I know it's not like the
best bandulus
that is not even that genre but there's
like if I ever need to get hype I listen
to uh I listen to Jekyll Jekyll and Hyde
by Five Finger Death Punch and I know
it's not like a great song but like I
can't help it like it gets really really
i'p and I know like it's it's just kind
of stupid or maybe it's not stupid I
have no idea I just feel I just feel
like every time I listen to it yeah so
it's it's super funny yeah
Oh tickets are still in stock oh yeah
they're definitely still in stock you
you can check them out I'm just saying
they're uh there's they're not I think
all the I have no idea just check it out
for yourself markiplier comm goes that
go the tickets check it out yeah I just
don't know how that guy talks like I
don't know how that guy whoever whatever
the name of the singer for that band is
how in the world does he not destroys
voice like I'm wanting to talk because
oh that was another thing that a lot of
people who like it makes me laugh I
totally get people care and they're
trying to be understanding they're
trying to be like you need to be careful
about your voice mark you know you don't
have heard it you don't a strain it and
I'm like do you understand
I have shouted for the past six years
straight
I have screamed for literally six years
straight almost six years straight now
like if there was damage to be done
Octodad already did that [ __ ] like that
was done a long time ago and I know
they're they're different mechanics of
singing but trust me when I say all of
this singing that I've done hasn't done
a dent to my voice that let's playing
will and even when I've been practicing
like I it's funny because when I when I
was starting like three months ago when
I was like I really like singing I
really think I like I really think I
like this and I want to do it I would I
didn't have a place where I could sing
not because like I I mean I'm in this
apartment right now and I'm able to do
this let's play and I'm able to talk but
when it comes to I know people can hear
me but I just don't care when it comes
to let's play when it comes to singing
like i like i tend Sall up and i can't
actually sing and i can't even think
about singing loud like I could scream
in here all I want because who cares I'm
surprised they haven't called the cops
on me but when it comes
singing I just I know I'm gonna get
reported like immediately like this guy
sucks I mean at least says let's play
voice was well a couple of decent but
God after listen to this cat dying over
there not on your life buddy not on your
life oh yeah yeah I rest him that'd be
great click okay and then that's that's
how that goes and it's so put Winokur so
what I do is I would just drive I would
drive and sing and and of course in LA
like traffic is so bad that you can't
like you can't drive anywhere during the
day so I would be driving at like 10
o'clock at night when the highways are
somewhat empty and that way I like like
I can just focus on driving and singing
my lungs out and at that point it was
not singing it was shouting like cuz I
didn't know the difference at that point
so I just be like right where we are and
I just be shouting at the top of my
lungs because number one I'm in a car
and you're driving and you can't hear
yourself anyway and I got the volume
cranked up to 10 like a max volume and
it's just like you couldn't hear
yourself anyway so like I couldn't hear
myself so I would just be shouting at
the top of my lungs and that didn't do
that dent to my voice I was totally fine
every single I'm good and I would drive
for hours to I'd be driving for hours
and hours and hours and it's just it's
just like like I'm all in all the
integrity and strength of my voice is
just fine I'm not gonna damage it by
anything that I'm doing but when it
comes to like refining it and and what
I've been learning like like obviously I
do know that I do know the difference
between chest voice head voice mix voice
falsetto I do know those differences in
the nuances of it but when it comes to
being able to do something right now I
don't have the strength in certain
aspects of it to be able to do it that
way so I have to do it other ways for
now as I build up later so that's why
that's why I do that's why I was doing
dangerous woman on Instagram with like
way to up there for the regice
that I was doing it I know that I'm
aware of that but also it's the only way
I could so but also I know myself and I
I know what's gonna hurt my voice and
what's not gonna hurt my voice so I knew
I was capable of doing it didn't sound
perfect buddy was good enough for what
it was and I did it just to piss people
hahaha that's another thing about me you
guys know that about me I'll if someone
tells me not to do something I go so far
in the opposite end of that spectrum of
to do that thing like people why what
people were like is like hey you know
that covers pretty good but maybe you
should sing like something a bit lower
I'm like how about I sing ariana grande
you shut up just because I'm petty like
that though that's what I say like I'm
an [ __ ] like that just goes like of
course I'm gonna do that yeah of course
I'm gonna do that yeah it's kind of like
why wouldn't I I just I'm petty like
that I will do that just to spite you
and make you mad at me like yeah part of
its also to prove like hey you know I am
not I'm not in your box you don't know
me and in other it's just like and why
not cuz cuz it's fun cuz it's fun that's
the point
it's fun that's all the point it's fun
anyway what was I talking about I'm no
idea Oh what do I do for vocal warmups I
do the basics probably that everyone
else does I do the Nenets I do the boom
you know doodly-doo blow now my eardrums
what do you have doodly-doo on loop
every time all right it looks like food
is doing pretty good oh we haven't
researched anything I'm an idiot I have
not been paying attention why do I not
have power regulation that's right I was
building my power grid and I didn't do
that okay I'm gonna get my head out of
my ass eventually and start doing what
I'm supposed to be doing
Little Italy yeah I have seen Jax drum
cover Jax drum cover actually is what
gave me courage to do my cover because I
like he'll confirm this when I when he
did that I like messaged him and I was
like dude that that covered was awesome
like and I was really impressed by it
even though he said technically like he
thought it wasn't very good because you
know his drumming wasn't perfect but I
couldn't tell I thought it was amazing
look I thought what he was doing was
perfect and like that's just like the
view of the uninitiated but it gave me
courage because what after that I was
like okay I'm not where I wanna be when
I put something out there but I got to
do something so that's good yeah I gotta
get something out there so I and then I
just did that so I got to give credit to
him for giving me the courage to do that
and it'll get better as they go on as I
go on and it's uh it's just like you
know it's just it's just it's gonna get
there eventually
oh thanks for coming to the door oh
thanks for buying a ticket oh you guys
are awesome thank you but when will you
sing another song I'll probably do more
mini covers on Instagram just because
it's very convenient place to do it and
that way I don't have to practice an
entire song I can just practice bits and
pieces of it and I think that's nice
just and also it just it gives me an
opportunity to do like other stuff like
I can already tell you I'm gonna try to
do some stuff like some mini covers of
like Shawn Mendes stuff and then like
some some random fun things that I think
are just entertaining for me like I
forget this is the song called Pony like
just if you want it let's do it ride it
mop Pony like I want to do actual I do a
little bit of that just cuz like I think
that's fun like why not like why
wouldn't I do that's why I did over at
the ariana grande song just cuz like
it's fun like why wouldn't I do it just
a little challenge why not I'm up to it
yeah so that's what I do
oh thanks for buying a ticket oh you
guys are so sweet I can't wait to see
you on the tour the show someone asks
how long the show's shows about it's
about 60 to 70 minutes of like us doing
the comedy part of it and then we do do
a Q&A at the end of it so it all that
works out to about 90 minutes maybe 75
ninety minutes what I'd say of actual
like show show depending on of course
how it goes because it is a little bit
different every time but it is what it
is um oh this game I haven't talked
about this game at all yeah this is
oxygen not included it's one of my
favorite games just because um it's a
very chill game and it looks like they
actually finished up this stuff so I can
start building downward now so I've got
what I've got here is I've got a big
base of Oh No
who can't let that touch okay that's not
good so what this is is this is germs
Yi's bad germs is by Ed germs yeah I
wasn't planning on doing any maroon5
don't worry about that I'm not actually
a fan but I'm sorry to anybody that is
advantage is like now my salad music
yeah do chats going too fast
that's going just just speedy enough for
me I can actually read this stuff so
what I have to do here is I have to keep
this water supply intact this is all the
water that I have right now which means
that once this runs out I'm done unless
I can filter it which is something that
I'm eventually gonna do what I'm gonna
do is now that I've got this cleared out
I'm gonna build a reservoir for polluted
water so that I can have that there and
then I'm gonna have a water filtration
system to be able to get it in here now
that the only problem with that is once
you have polluted water with germs in it
the filtration system will not remove
the germs so if you have that dumping
back into your normal water supply then
you have the problem of suddenly there's
food poisoning everywhere with food
poisoning not that bad you can deal with
food poisoning but when it comes to
slime lung that'll kill your duplicants
so if you once you get to the point
where you're filtering out that I don't
even know how to do that I think you
have to boil the water to be able to
clean that out there and I am NOT to the
point where I even know how to boil the
water so you shall see about that it's
no way that this is real it's pretty
real it's pretty real pretty real I mean
to not make it real but as real as I can
imagine it being okay but other than
that we're gonna figure this [ __ ] out I
don't know how I think if I build food
here and then make the food here make
the water treatment thing here because
eventually I gotta get showers right I'm
gonna put the showers right here - right
there so it's kind of in the central of
everything and then people can go the
shower but then that shower has to be
able to dump somewhere then I'm gonna be
able to contain for a long time so what
I got to do is I gotta build like I got
a build how's your mouth so stretchy ah
well I gotta build the reservoir right
here-ish probably yeah I guess I'm gonna
assume that keep it out of the grand at
unless this is where things actually get
a little like meticulous cuz you gotta
actually planned and if you don't do it
right you're gonna ruin everything and
then everything is gonna be terrible and
you're gonna die and everything's bad
like that's just how it's gonna be but
what you gotta do is you gotta build
that and you know careful didn't build
your okay so they're gonna build that
and then what I'm gonna do over here is
I'm gonna build more food processing
food processing whatever it's just food
so they're I know I could build farm
tiles but I don't need them yet so I'm
not gonna do that
god damn it I bet those off-center
this cuz that annoys me I'm gonna fix
that and make that like that
there we go and then this is not there
yeah okay there we go all right so when
they build that out I'm gonna build some
more food supply so that we don't run
out of that and then what I love about
this game for streaming is that I only
have to like dedicate brainpower to it
in short fits and bursts and then
they're set to task and then they do
that and that leaves me time to chat
with you yes I will be playing evil
within - hell yeah you think I wouldn't
oh of course I would oh of course I
would you think I wouldn't oh you're
gonna see me in January oh thanks guys
oh and yeah someone asked some yeah Bob
Wade Tyler and Ethan are also gonna be
part of the tour they're gonna be part
of the show like the show wouldn't be
the show without them so how crude is
the show do you mean do we curse or
something like it's not crude at all
we actually don't really we try to avoid
cursing on when we're doing the show how
crude I've never even been asked that so
yeah it's just what it is
oh gosh I'm getting so many song
suggestions no I'm not gonna start a
band anytime soon a lot of people are
looking you need to start a band now
it's like no I I don't want to do that
see I don't see the thing about me and
singing is a lot of people assume that
like just cuz I'm singing stuff or I'm
putting stuff out there it means that
I'm gonna be uh it means that I'm gonna
be like making an album it means that
I'm gonna be doing going on tour for
singing like that's not the point of
what I'm doing it I'm doing it because
it's fun and it's a fun creative outlet
I'm not doing it for profit I'm not
doing it so that I can make my career
out of it I'm not doing it so that I can
be like the world's greatest singer I'm
doing it so that I can be the best
singer that I can be and hopefully show
you guys on the way not for the sake of
doing it because it's the thing I'm best
at it may end up being the thing I'm not
best at but right now it's the thing I
want to pursue so I'm doing it so that I
can see how good I can be at it and then
after we get to that point seeing where
it takes me because that's the only way
that you can look at creative things
like you can
look at them as being you're like paint
check you can't look at it being like I
have to be good at this because my
livelihood depends on it you do it
because you love it and then if it can
lead to something where you can survive
on that and do it then you do it like
that's amazing that but that is very
rare for me like when I did Let's Plays
I wanted to do Let's Plays in videos
because I loved it because I loved
making videos and I loved doing it if it
didn't work out to a job that was fine I
wasn't counting on it I was still in
school for engineering because I thought
that's what I was gonna be doing and I
was just like I knew I needed to change
it to be able to do something but I
didn't count on it being what I wanted
it wasn't until I was like a year in and
then I got to the point where oh [ __ ]
this could be my job I have to make a
decision that's when I made the decision
that oh [ __ ] I need to commit to this
because this is what I want to do I want
to do this more than engineering that's
when I made the decision you don't make
the decision before you've done it like
no no your god no you don't do that way
before the fact cuz otherwise like what
could you do you you wouldn't succeed at
it because you'd have so much pressure
of being good at it you'd never be you
at it you know what I mean so like I'm
not approaching that singing the same
way it's something that I find really
entertaining and really fun and it's
it's a it's a wonderful adventure to be
able to practice it with the way that I
am but I'm not gonna be looking at it to
do an album for I'm not gonna be looking
at it to compare myself to anybody else
because that would ruin it for me you
know what I mean make sense okay anyway
rambling enough it's just little plants
have died what are you talking about
women no plants have died there we talk
about yeah anyway that's just my two
cents about if you guys are thinking
about making something your career don't
think about that first you have to do it
first because what you love can change
and that's that's that sometimes even
more important than like doing the thing
in in the long run is you you may love
it in the beginning but as you get
more into it you may realize that it's
not what you want and there's no there's
no harm in that there's no harm in just
going like I tried it I liked it at
first didn't like it afterwards okay
that's the end of it god damn it why do
you have to be a mouth breather go away
I don't want you anyway
yeah so anyway that's that's what it is
and that's my philosophy on it and
that's what got me to where I am today
I'm not saying that's the best
philosophy but it is the philosophy that
made me the youtuber I am today and I
still have things to improve on but
that's just because like I have no time
as the thing right like I don't have
time the reason like my schedule gets
wonky and I am gonna be getting back on
that very soon like I want to be I want
to be like I wanna be I want to be
making videos that like make me super
happy and not to say that Let's Plays
are bad but like I've done Let's Plays
for a long time and I'm now I'm not
gonna stop doing Let's Plays like
obviously I'm doing a stream basically a
let's play right here but when it comes
to pushing myself like I I'm the type of
person that always has to push myself
and I push myself really hard but that's
that's why I'm good at stuff and that's
why I'm good at anything is because I
have very high expectations for myself
and I throw my I'm a workaholic so I
dedicate myself fully so when it comes
to looking at my videos like every day I
look at him and my standard for how
pleased I am you know that grows like
what I was talking about before if you
were listening I was talking about how
my my cover is reaches my expectations
for what I can do right now and then
that'll increase my expectations for
Let's Plays like it's kind of plateaued
like there's only so good you can be
there's no way that I could be laughs
out loud
belly laugh hilarious every single
second of every single video I try to
make my videos as entertaining as
possible but when it comes to a let's
place it there's only so much that you
can do and it's like so it can get stale
when your your ability to exceed your
expectations kind of slows down you know
what I mean and I've still got room to
make progress but that doesn't mean that
I'm I'm always going to get better Minh
just comes down to factors that you
can't
control like what type of game you're
playing or what game you're playing you
that's less fulfilling then everything
riding on your own shoulders and by the
seat of your pants like when when it
comes down to other videos now again
like I said I'm not gonna stop doing
Let's Plays because I find it fun and
because I enjoy it that's what I'm gonna
do but when it comes down to other
things like you really got to evaluate
like is this like how can I improve this
mm I at my peak of my own skill or is
there more that I can do you know what I
mean that's what you got to decide and
that's what you got to figure out as you
go through what you're doing so anyway
that did enough Lizzy Oh both some of
the garbage gamer says [ __ ] mark
you've never done all you can do Let's
Plays brought you here and you can
always make some entertaining yeah I get
that but that's not what I'm saying
like Let's Plays brought me to this
point and that doesn't mean that I can
get I can't get better at it that's not
what I'm saying
your progress slows though like if you
look at it you get better really quickly
at something but then you like getting
that next percentage of goodness takes
more effort and more time and then it
reaches this kind of bell curve of
mastering something and I'd say that
over those five and a half years of
doing Let's Plays I'm really damn good
at doing Let's Plays but improving at it
becomes harder and and one of the
biggest like things in my life that
drives me into what I do is always
chasing self-improvement
you know what I mean chasing it
relentlessly hounding it like always
wanting to be better at it like really
chasing that and so when it comes to
getting to the point where that may not
meet my expectations every single time
you would get to a point where you like
I want to find that thing that I can't
exceed that when it comes to making
videos like I always want to reach
higher and I want to see where I can go
more you know what I mean so that's what
I mean by that I'm not saying and again
not saying I'm gonna this happens every
time I talk about this not stop doing
Let's Plays but
other videos that are let's plays that
do push creativity and are something
that I can learn and really try to be
better at make sense okay cool all right
back your memes back to your means and
whatnot I got to get concentrating on
this because I'm not doing it okay what
do we got going on here I don't dig that
out okay so we got a basin for the
polluted water to eventually go into we
will get that underway and I'm gonna
build this ladder preemptively so that I
don't have to worry about later Valgard
conquering a looter let's see oh you
just got a ticket
oh thanks hello myself you got you are
awesome I appreciate that can't wait to
see you during the show so we got enough
food supply for these four people we
could probably increase that to another
lake maybe we could go for six people
but I'm gonna hold off on that stress is
still a bit high so I'm gonna start
thinking about the art of the place
because the decorum is just very poor in
this environment so we got that okay
we're gonna build this like it's gonna
preemptively give them something to do
I'm gonna chew at these these are pretty
good for environment but we're gonna put
one I hate this doubling and this
doubling is no good
mm gotta go
decorum well that's pretty okay
yeah dad looks nice
oh that's real dice oh that's so dice
okay
put you right there okay well give him
some of them chew on ya
oh god Diego Lara you got a ticket thank
you so much if you don't know what I'm
talking about the tickets for the tour
available in markiplier com there's a
link right down there in the description
go there check it out catch something
see us beat funny live I can't wait to
do it no it's right around the corner
I'm so excited
two weeks away I'm so excited for I
can't wait to go oh man it's just like
I've been itching to go on this tour
again because yeah I'm streaming hello
alright guys hello hi just because like
it's so fun I can't even explain how fun
it is
oh god it's super fun so I just can't
wait to do yeah it's not by the way want
to be right clear there's no
meet-and-greet in this like it's not a
meet-and-greet this is not a tour where
we come onstage and do a panel no this
is a plan show it's big and it's fun and
it's so cool and it's hopefully funny
but even if it's not funny like it's
still fun like that's that's like the
that's like the most important thing
about it right like even if it's not
even if it's not uh it's not like super
hilarious which I think you I think it's
gonna be like eventually it's gonna be
but it's uh it's why did I have you guys
not built this one tile this poor plan
has just been dying here and you guys
have let it die bastards okay Little
Edie come to Sioux Falls maybe will you
be streaming the tour no but we will be
doing a lot of tour goofs and stuff on
the tour we're gonna be making so many
silly videos more on the tour it was
gonna be amazing I can't wait for it
but up until that point we will we will
not be streaming the tour itself Oh is
anybody good at art now whatever I don't
care
well thank you
have I ever considered starting a
business uh I mean technically I guess
YouTube is a business for me I have a
business for the channel which is weird
to say but it's only just for like
organizational purposes that way I can
hire people when it comes to a business
like it would have to be something that
I'm really really really interested in
like like um it would have to be
something that I'm number-one passionate
about and it would have to be in a point
of my life where and I could dedicate
all of my time to it because when it
comes to a business like I can't just
hire someone else to run the business
for me I would want to do the business
myself to the best of my ability
you know what I mean now that's what it
would have to be there's no other way
that I could do it and I would be happy
with what I was doing
it would have to be so yeah that's just
a long the short of it I couldn't do it
otherwise yeah what am i drinking in
pure vodka water
no I'm not gonna start abandon no I'm
not gonna play life is strange
no no get those stupid things out there
what do you think you're doing talking
to me with those words no way yeah is it
good water yeah good that's all I drink
really so battened some diet sodas
that's it I've kind of cut a lot of
other liquids besides just water out of
my life this is better overall ooh
clay I don't care about play was it
clear they did add in pockets of like
sand so you can have more filtration
medium why is that only five kilograms
what five that doesn't make any sense
that's supposed to be way more than five
all right whatever so that's not a very
big pocket of it but it looks like I'm
probably gonna be venturing off this way
first as my base expands but as the
sands right now it's gonna be a bit of a
challenge oh you're coming to Atlanta
thanks for getting a ticket the tour is
not in New York just because that's the
way the tickets worked out like the
venue's I'm so sorry about that we will
if we do this tour again after this leg
which we're hoping to do in Canada and
Australia and more in America but we
just uh it's just a scheduling thing
like it's so hard to do yeah we'll get
there eventually though virtual hug
Oh hug Huggle honey hugs all around
everybody good hug oh you're coming to
Berlin I can't wait to get there yeah I
will oh I can't play the guitar right
now um I don't have my uh well I mean I
could I don't have my good guitar with
me it's it's a really really shitty
guitar it's up oh oh
that's out of tune but I'm not gonna
bother doing it well you think I can
tune something by ear no ha ha oh my god
oh my huh when your legs don't work like
they used to before
oh my god and I can't me will your mouth
still remember the taste of my love
[Music]
little by little brubber cheeks and
darling I will yeah so I got this shitty
guitar it's not tuned so yeah
hey do you guys think I'm good at
singing and guitar Dow - still think I
have a future in it oh say I do oh my
God look at this [ __ ]
max narcoleptic noodle arms biohazardous
put he's a quick learner he touches try
oh good god he would die so fast
oh no wait you got +4 digging but you
got trip to phobia what are you even
doing with your life get out of here all
of you are terrible I don't want any of
you yeah oh no this isn't a charity
stream this is just me just be streaming
because I'm feel like doing a goof yeah
that's all the streams about this is
anything anyone would tolerate
sponsoring this thing no this is just
for goofs yeah but yeah for those asking
yeah I know the schedule has been all
over the place the schedule is coming
back in order I'm open to starting
tomorrow just to be back on the 8 and 12
train I just had to dedicate all of my
time to doing - practicing for the the
cover song the dad that amazing thing
can't you tell the basic practice I've
been doing yeah it's pretty good wait
let me see Jane juris woman for you you
guys ready cover your ears it's about to
get bad never remember somethin bout
somethin bout you
baby feel like a dangerous woman about
you they wanna do things that I should I
warned you I warned about that
warned you tried to warn you anyway well
okay everybody is now deaf alright well
thanks for stopping yeah that guitar is
I need to burn that guitar this is not
doing okay all right so they they just
finished up the tasks they were doing so
I can actually focus on this stuff
finish these out
doodlee doodlee doodlee do okay what
should we do next guys well how can we
improve tiny butthole
what can tiny butthole do here well what
we need to do eventually what we need to
do is we need to get more researching
because we gotta get the rest of these
research trains out we should get
filtration just because obviously we
should but I guess I should work on
getting their uh their showers up in
order because this is gonna help out
their stress levels a lot the big babies
so what I'm gonna eventually do is I'm
gonna put a pump down here but I just I
mean I'm I'm gonna need it eventually so
there's no harm in it so I'm gonna put a
pump down there get a ladder down there
so they don't drown themselves again
yeah this game is called oxygen not
included you sound like a beautiful
angle thank you oh thank you thank you
very much
fix the double ladder oh yeah that's
right I should fix that but the question
is how cuz I blocked it off with this
mediocre painting I should have thought
about that a little bit you know it's a
charming double ladder or what are you
gonna do I'm gonna this is all gonna be
scrapped eventually anyway didn't read
redone so uh why bother doing it now why
why why do I do what I could do today
what I can put off for future me to do
you know
that's the ideal right then why why do
today I'm very lazy so no why no shows
in New York because we hate New York
that's why no cuz we didn't have any
venues that we could get in New York we
only had eleven options there's 50
states like what can we do someone's
gonna be disappointed I don't know
nowaday it all came down to the venues
and I didn't I didn't have a I will I
will because if you go for one place
someone else is gonna be this boy we
just do what we could we swear it wasn't
personal we tried anyway enough about
that what is my daily motivation oh I
talked about this earlier but some
people may not have been here for my
daily motivation what I was I was doing
this morning it was amazing I well I
wasn't amazing it was actually problems
like psychotic but now I was uh I got up
this morning and I was I imagined there
was these two sports commentators like
football commentators in my head talking
about everything that I was doing so
when I put my pants on there was like oh
man mark is off to a great start this
morning putting his pants on one leg at
a time I can't believe how good I look I
can't believe it either
yeah like that guy he is astonishing
everything oh my goodness he's making
himself breakfast water champion he's
really going the distance in this one
and if you just imagine these two these
two guys that are just so enthusiastic
about every single tiny detail that you
do with us getting out of bed putting
clothes on brushing your teeth taking a
shower like anybody don't do that like
you just shut down the computer and
you'd be lazy they're just like oh what
a master of his craft like made me smile
is absolutely crazy to do but hey it
made me smile so I can't complain about
it all right what do we got is it time
to break this open and contaminate this
this is gonna be a horrible horrible
place yeah before we do that we got to
build um you got to build the UH we're
gonna do is we're gonna make a a washing
station because there shouldn't be much
reason for people to come in and out of
here
but any place that has
any possibility of contamination best
just leave that be
you know what I'm saying yeah so that's
gonna be there and then oh do I have oh
I don't know if that research has been
done
I need where was it
Oh sanitation I did have it so this is
what I've left this spot for was for
this the breathalyzer and then I'm also
gonna have it here because this is gonna
be a big you're gonna be a big big
depository for a lot of contaminated air
so I'm gonna keep that right there so
it's at the crux of everything in vini
there will be merch on the tour we have
special tour merch the amazing art that
was made by Victor ah no for the tour
it's just amazing stuff I love it a lot
so we're gonna get we're gonna get out
there pretty soon yeah UK tour dates VIP
tickets they're available right now the
UK tour dates and the the January tour
dates they're all available at
markiplier com go down there there's a
link down there in the description and
you can find all the information along
with everything else right there so go
for there who's my comedic inspiration
Brian Regan uh yeah is there anybody
else to be inspired by yeah not only
Brian Regan but also louis c.k i but I
haven't really been um gosh I haven't
really been I haven't been listening to
a lot of stand-up specials I really
should like I get so focused on one
thing I'm like oh yeah that thing I love
I forgot about that because I work
pretty much like from the moment I get
up to the moment I go to bed I'm working
and I love it like but I I just don't
get really a break to do stuff that I
can casually enjoy unless I can compound
it with something else like watching uh
watching some Netflix or something while
I'm editing a video or
while I'm doing some work like in the
background or making thumbnails or
something like that so yeah that's
that's what I got to do oh this is uh
this is oxygen not included still love
me anyway what did I do
what does it do Brian Regan yeah yeah
how much are the tickets they vary
depending on the seat I think the the
cheapest is about the cheapest is gonna
run you about like 25 to 30 and then
they go up from there so the VIP tickets
are are expensive but you get in early
and then I'm gonna do my acoustical set
in that in that moment so it should be
for pretty fun I'm gonna do like a
thirty minute thing and just chat with
you guys so I'm nervous about that one
but I think you guys will forgive me if
I'm terrible because you've already seen
I'm pretty durable but yeah it's still
fun I can't wait for it though the
squirrels need their king about that
okay but I'm going to get the I'm gonna
get them showers that's one thing oh
that's the other thing I have to do I
have to make oh crap I totally forgot
about that I have to do I have to make
the power thing that's right god I'm
such an idiot god I can't even think
about that I think my my duplicates are
idiots I'm a frickin idiot
that's what I was all I was why did I
put a letter up there I was gonna build
the insulation thing because the the big
problem about building a giant power
depository is it generates a lot of heat
and eventually you'll be able to use
that heat to your advantage but in the
initial phases it's super problematic so
what we need you need that and then you
need the power regulation of the power
transformers because these are all the
step downs that you need to be able to
make the power stuff yeah how can I read
that fast I don't know I've always been
able to read that fast oh yeah of course
the guys from whose line is it anyway
those guys are definitely like an
inspiration for me like
I love all of that and those guys are
just like super funny but has the new
season come out are they doing another
season because they rebooted whose line
is it anyway and it was really good but
I haven't heard much about it so I hope
they're still doing it no no no yeah
eventually I'll get there hopefully okay
but once they build that we're gonna
research up Yeti I need I need the
insulation Stiles Stiles to be able to
insulate it in because what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna build a big bank of
batteries and the objective is build as
many batteries as you can fit in a space
because then I'm gonna build like coal
plants and the coal plants will just
keep going and eventually you fill these
batteries up so high that they will be
able to run themselves completely and
then build these smaller substations of
just these manual generators so that you
can power smaller projects like this and
that way it's not regulated by the giant
power substation
but hopefully like if whether that's
gonna be able to be done like depends on
what I'm gonna be doing it yeah
what's my another other dream job I
don't know I'm lucky I get to do my
dream job I get to be here with you guys
I get to make videos and they you guys
enjoy and I get to talk with you guys so
like that's that's as much as a dream
job as I could ever hope for
yeah so it's nice oh thanks for buying
tickets guys yeah cuz cuz being here I'm
not ignoring you you see how many people
are right here you think I'm ignoring
you now I'm not ignoring you but that
that's what's amazing about this Oh loud
sleeper you've got a lot of good stats
mmm all right Frankie
I'm gonna go for you for your bed
hopefully that's far enough away god
alright well guess you're gonna have an
isolation chamber aren't you well you
did this to yourself so I can't really I
can't really do much about that but oh
well that's fine what does that even do
does it just make him tired I guess huh
I guess it's not that bad yeah but I'll
fix it eventually baby Turner deserves
and maybe I could switch that to Abe
because Abe is just a giant douche and
can't handle his own bladder and fix it
eventually all right we'll fix that
we'll just make these double massagers
and give uh give some nice decor for
Franky over here in the flaxseed of
course pretty nice over there can it
still reach can still reach oh it could
still reach nice okay so that's good oh
yeah oh yeah I forgot about that what
was the game last light the light game
with Nico what was it oh I do need to
play that guy keep forgetting about
these yet I've got so many things that
like I need to do like I need someone to
make a list of the things that I say I
need to do cuz I've got that big old
game suggestions list but I need a list
that's like hey you said you were gonna
do this I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah I did okay
good call like I need I need that list
of things that I like I said I'm
supposed to do
oopsies Oh what can you do come on
finish up this gotta get those
insulation tiles up in there
we're gonna build a bad boy and the
reason I put it up top is because in
this game heat rises so you definitely
know one heat on the bottom to do that
but the main problem of building such a
big battery bank like that is it the
heat doesn't go away ideally you put
that big battery bank in an ice biome
but I don't see a nice biome anywhere
around here there's just nothing so
that's the sand I want the 5000 kilogram
sand that's the good stuff right there
oh yeah oh yeah
good yeah but anyway this is what it is
did I will I ever get over my fear of
singing for others I kind of have
actually that's another reason why I
wanted to do the cover is because it was
a big step for me to be able to do sing
in front of other people and what better
way to do that in front of the Internet
but it's it's also a completely
different beast when you do it in front
of like when you sing in front of in
front of like a crowd or something like
that cuz I'm great onstage and I'm great
I could talk onstage all I want but even
the thought of singing like onstage just
you should you sheesh okay yes yeah yeah
oh yeah I need the heavy heavy power
yeah the advanced power regulation
that's what I need so they got that set
to task and that's gonna go yeah shout
out to everybody that's asking for a
shout out now never gonna shout out
again yeah but I'm gonna get that I get
that pole dancing video is coming
someone make a list someone make that
list someone make that list of all the
things that I said I was gonna do so
that I can have it in one place and I
can look like okay and then I can start
checking things off and then just update
that whenever whenever I promise
something else in blam do that yeah so
uh and then add on to that list a days
since schedule has been missed you know
like days since last accident days since
schedule missed like do that I'd love to
have one of those yeah super fun but
it's all it's all in good good good
taste because like that's that's the
most important thing that I've found
lately and I have to go but I'm gonna
wrap this up with some parting words of
mine like just the thing that I've that
has kept me going and what I what I do
is always remembering why I'm doing it
and the biggest reason that I do what I
do is because of you guys and that's
again it's not me I said in that floor
vlog it's not me like kissing your ass
Tommy blowing smoke up your ass like I
always remember that I'm
because you guys allow me to be here
there's no other reason there's no other
way around I'm not if it weren't for you
guys I would not be here
plain and simple there's no fussing
around that so always remembering that
and the reason I do things is also
because I find it fun and you guys
understand that it's funny it's why I'm
playing this game because I find this
game super fun even though it may not
seem like I'm doing a lot I find this
game fun so like in everything that you
do and everything that we do as people
or as like like in anything creatively
it has to be something fun so when I
when I when I when I miss like a video
and I'm gonna try very hard not to do
that in the future but when I miss a
video it's because I'm making something
I really like and I'm doing something
because I'm always working like if the
worst thing that I could possibly think
is that people think that I'm being lazy
and I'm not working when a videos missed
its scheduled mark know that opposite
I'm working on something that I'm loving
and that's like the heart of everything
because if I'm not doing what I
absolutely love then like that shows
like you guys see it you guys know
you're not stupid you're smart like you
can see when things are good and when
things are bad and so when you have that
very clear distinction and you just go
to yourself and you acknowledge like
okay all right I if if I am this person
that's on the internet I'm here because
people like me you know hopefully anyway
or they want to see me crash and burn
that's another that's another
alternative either don't worry that's
coming the crew the crash and burn is
coming but it's like you know so in
order to be the best me I can be I have
to focus on what makes me me you know
that didn't make any sense at all but
you know what I'm saying like that's
that's what I love and I love being here
with you guys and I love doing this show
for you guys when it comes to the tour
like that's don't play the guitar yeah
that's the attitude ooh there I just saw
a comic go by like go please well you
know what I'm gonna do because whenever
you tell made it do something I do the
opposite so everybody get ready for a a
sweet ditty
a whole Wow where your legs will work
like they used to before no yeah yeah
it's it's just fun it's fun life is
really good right now and I I can't wait
to see what the future holds like it's
it's an amazing thing and and and that's
what I would actively encourage you guys
it's never stopped trying never stopped
going for that thing that you get
excited for never stop don't let anyone
tell you to stop unless your thing is
murdering people then please for the
love of God stop and then don't do that
uh but you know it's it's important to
chase what makes you good when not even
what makes you good chase what makes you
feel fulfilled and I would never I would
never want anyone to stop that so anyway
uh if you want a tour ticket they're
available down there markiplier comm
check it out for yourself they're gonna
be available for a little bit longer
our show is in two weeks we're going on
tour two weeks and it'll be so much fun
so check that out if you haven't gotten
one already get excited if you do
because I know the shows are gonna be
great and just thank you everybody so
much for joining me
yeah I will have more covers probably
I'll just put them on Instagram and if I
do a full one maybe in the future I'll
do it in in YouTube but don't expect
those to be like super regular but
expect me to keep practicing it every
day because I just I love it yeah
so thank you everybody so much for
watching I got to get out of here but uh
you're awesome
stay awesome and keep chasing what makes
you happy so thanks again and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
bye bye guys bye guys see ya yeah Oh
creams going good yeah I know I saw that
before but yeah Koreans going good I'm
still learning from my mom I'm getting
really good at it I'm young eat I know I
never gonna say oh I'm young annyeonghi
gaseyo is it wait if I'm staying and
you're going do I say on young age I say
oh that's confusing there's different
ways of saying goodbye depending on
where you are annyeonghi gyeseyo
like comes out neither
go mop some go mop some indeed ah that's
there's like two ways to thank thank you
come on something that gums I'm neither
like anyway bye see ya you guys going
off to be a kpop star sure sure